hundreds of afghan government troops
have fled across the border into
tajikistan as the taliban captures
more territory taliban fighters took
several districts in the northern
province of badachan this weekend
after afghan soldiers fled their posts
the afghan government says it's sending
reinforcements
since america's drawdown of troops
gained pace in may
well the taliban has doubled the number
of districts it holds
now as many afghans live under tanaban
rule
as those in government controlled areas
13 districts fell to the group on
saturday
the most in 20 years
thanks to god and this was proven before
that the majority of the afghan people
in the previous era during the taliban
rule for more than 10 years
we are now in control of more than 70 of
the territories
it is simply because the people know us
very well and the afghan people have no
problem dealing with us
we have two main principles that we rely
on when it comes to judgment
first is the blessed islamic faith and
the second is our belief in our national
identity
within the framework of these two
principles i can assure you that we do
not have
any problem with anyone we respect
everyone's right
the majority of u.s and nato forces have
now left afghanistan ahead of a
september 11th departure deadline
just 650 american troops are staying
back
to secure the u.s embassy and kabul
airport
let's get a sense of who controls what
in afghanistan as we mentioned the
taliban is seizing districts right
across the north
they've been fighting and winning across
the country
districts shaded in orange are
government
controlled contested districts
are in green that means taliban fighters
may have surrounded population centers
main cities or villages in the area
districts in purple are firmly under
taliban control
the number of districts and who controls
them is disputed
let's talk to fahim sadat he is a
political and security analyst as well
as head of international relations
department
at kardan university joins us on skype
from kabul good to have you with us so
first of all
why is the taliban now advancing so fast
see uh the taliban are uh having
operations across afghanistan in all the
zones if it is north south east or west
but what is strange is that they are
facing
less resistance in the north of
afghanistan
um and and basically their
intensification of
violence is because after the security
withdrawal
of the for coalition forces from
afghanistan
a security vacuum has been created and
taliban
are capitalizing over that vacuum which
has been created by the withdrawal
now so that is why they have intensified
the
the the the conflict and are having
fast battlefield gains particularly in
the north of afghanistan
this will these battlefield gains will
definitely strengthen
the taliban's position in any coming
negotiations if that is to happen and as
well as this has
sent shock waves from the morale
perspective
within the government rank-and-file okay
before we get into the negotiations
we've seen
some countries like russia iran pakistan
india limiting or
closing down their of consular
operations in places like
balch province not a very good sign of
confidence
i mean does that mean basically many
expect the taliban
influence to grow even further
well looking at the strategic retreat
particularly that is happening
in in north afghanistan the
people who have
consulates over there should be
concerned uh
because the taliban are on a rapid
advance
in the north and that adds to the
ambiguity of the situation
but it is it is at the same time to the
government
to prove the doubters wrong
and strike back and show
the the the ability and as well as the
capability of retaking
the lost territories or districts to the
taliban
so that it makes sure that it has the
ability
to keep the population safe i think that
will help
with the with the neighboring countries
uh to to regain the
lost confidence all right is what is the
taliban strategy
now as you see it is their strategy
simply
to make enough gains to gain sufficient
leverage on the negotiating table
assumedly with the afghan government
or do they think they can completely
militarily defeat the afghan government
i think uh the the first purpose is more
more uh there i i personally believe
that as i said before the security
vacuum that has been created
taliban are capitalizing over that and
and basically
they are uh capturing the rural areas
in northern in all of over the
afghanistan where they can
so in the short term they i think the
their focus is right now on the
battlefield gains but
as the fall close closes in afghanistan
where looking at the mountainous regions
in the north
that does not which is not a very battle
friendly environment then
i think the taliban will return back to
negotiations
but until that the spring and summer
offensives
and the battlefield gains which taliban
are having now
will be definitely used in order to
strengthen their position on the
negotiating table
all right good to get your thoughts
thank you so much for him said that
you're welcome pleasure embattled prime
minister abby ahmed is facing multiple
challenges both at home and abroad
a worsening famine together with a
military conflict that's far from being
over in tigrai
and a diplomatic dispute over